How's it going bros, my name is PewDiePie,
and welcome to Fridays With PewDiePieeee!
Alright, I'm gonna sit down for this video,
just so that... you know what, fuck you, you can't control me....
*breaking sound* That was so unnecessary.
This screw got loose??
I'm pretty sure...
this is gonna bite me in the ass later!
Official Moriigon: "is it just me or was PewDiePie about to vape?"
No.
"What's the name of the music in the beginning?"
I don't fucking know....
Just check the description!
Like everyone fucking else,
Darude Sandstorm!
*crazed laughter* *Darude Sandstorm playing*
"He's wearing the same shirt in the other laughing challenge vid."
Yeah, I don't know about you bros but sometimes I wear the same outfit twice.
I know, it's, uh, Fashion Police,
Please don't arrest me or anything like that.
Hey, I bet you're sitting in your fucking sweatpants with your fucking Cheetos all over your sh- I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
"What's wrong with watching anime?"
"Same, he's just an immature
nearsighted person who thinks watching anime is a weird thing.
It's the same concept as western cartoon, but some people just don't get that."
You sound like one of those people that preach about marijuana.
"Uh, it's so much better than alcohol. "
"I don't understand how it could be illegal."
"It's so healthy and good for you."
*laughs*
I watch anime. I, I make sarcastic jokes.
I love anime.
I can make a Top-10 anime list
and I'd be having a full-on erection the whole time, but
I like to make jokes, you know?
Humor.
I love Zelda, it's one of my favorite animes.
Think about it this way:
if I say something that's a bit out of the ordinary, maybe you should go like
"Hey, maybe he's being sarcastic."
"Oh my god! I thought I was the only one with cream phobia. Hate putting cream on, ugh, it's so cringy"
Thank you, Clara Sofia!
I hate creams... SO much.
Noo...
I feel like I'm gonna puke, this is so fucking gross.
Fuck creams.
"Youtube whooooore."
Oh man, Youtube Whore is probably one of my favorite videos.
It got taken down for copyright
because of offensive material.
I was in Youtube's call, it was the song that I used.
Like I bought the license for the song
but technically, if it's seen as offensive material, the license gets voided.
It's really weird.
I'm working on to get it back up.
"You listen to Nickelback."
Remember when I was talking about being sarcastic?
I mean, honestly, Nickelback is not that bad.
It's just, they look like fucking idiots.
I know music is about the ears.
But like, do you really wanna listen to this guy in your ears?
"Bring Pewds Does Everything back."
Pewds Does Everything - I love those videos.
They were great.
I don't wanna make them anymore.
The reason why is because I upload every single day.
And for me to make one of those videos in one day is a hell of a lot lot of a job.
Like twice it happened that I got
a panic attack from doing it because
my body was just so tired of doing all these crazy shit
cause I am doing everything
and uh...
It's just... anytime I think about
doing a new episode I keep thinking about how shit I feel and I'm like
I'm not enjoying this process of making this video.
The result is great but making the video is horrible and it's not worth it and I don't feel like doing it.
So, sorry.
"I have so much more respect for him now that he listens to Nickelback."
Are you guys sarcastic now?
"Is he still with Marzia?"
Trust me, if me and Marzia broke up, you would know about it.
Like, stop trying to read into small things.
It's so weird.
"Go back to the way you were in 2015."
Everyone on the internet is always preaching so much
about how you shouldn't say this person is fat
or you shouldn't say this person is this and that,
but for some reason everyone feels so entitled to tell someone how to act.
Like, "go back to the way you were in 2015."
That's so fucking weird as hell to say to someone.
Like - and you have the weirdest fucking avatar, like, fuck off, honestly.
"Why? Why the bodysuit thing?"
*awkward silence*
Because of comments like this. *laughs*
"If PewDiePie hates and says that drama is the worst thing,
then why did he make drama with- wit KSI the next day?
Well, KSI tweeted me and I just responded.
I don't see how that is me making drama.
It's even so like, me and KSI are on good terms.
We don't hate each other.
You can disagree with someone and still be fine.
Everyone else is blowing this shit up so much more than it is.
And that was part of the point of me making the drama video
and what I was talking about.
No one seems to care anyway. Fuck uh-
Fuck everyone. Jesus Christ.
"For me you will be best forever, you did an awesome job
and I find your videos still better and better, thank you for everything you do for Bros."
That's very sweet. Thank you.
I was so happy with their- their feedback that I got from the
"Old VS New PewDiePie video."
I feel like I'm finally at a point where I am proud of the content that I make.
Like this guy: "I want him to play Amnesia again."
Even though a lot of people want me to make a lot of other type of videos,
I'm making the videos that I'll enjoy making.
Sure, I could still upload another part of Happy Wheels,
and people would enjoy it,
even though I did God knows how many.
But I wouldn't enjoy making those videos.
I feel like, yes, I would probably get more views and subscribers
if I catered to my audience more.
But I think I'm good. You know what, I think I'm alright.
I think I'll be okay either way.
And that doesn't mean I don't care about what you guys say,
it's just that I wanna make stuff that I'm proud of.
"So this title and thumbnail literally had nothing to do with the actual video?"
I remember this comment.
*laughs*
I got a lot of comments about this because
the title and thumbnail were something that was in the end of the video.
Like the vlog, for example.
What do you guys think about the title and thumbnail?
I just try to do something that people would wanna click on.
I feel like I have the content and the entertainment is there.
I just need to get people in the video.
I don't feel like I'm misleading anyone, you know what I mean.
There's a thin line that you kind of have to pick.
"What happened to the dog's eye?"
I'm guessing you're asking about Maya.
Maya lost her eye before we got her
and she's not bothered with it so it's okay.
"Don't shave your bird."
I won't.
"Your girlfriend is adorable."
Were you hitting on my girl, bitch?
"You don't use AdBlock." I use AdBlock.
There's a lot of fucking annoying websites.
I greenlight it on Youtube which basically means it's not on on Youtube.
If everyone used AdBlock, I wouldn't be able to do what I'm doing.
And that doesn't mean I only make videos just to make money.
I made videos over a year before I made any money on them.
I just wasn't able to do it on such a frequent basis.
Even if Youtube turned off their way of making like ads-, ad revenue,
I would still make videos.
I just wouldn't be able to do it at the same frequency as now.
I have a lot of respect for what I do and
even though my channel is so silly and so stupid,
I take it very seriously.
That was a total different answer to the question. *laughs*
But I hope it makes sense.
"The people that filmed him must feel so weird"
I bet they do feel weird, but we also have a lot of fun shooting together, like
it's not some weird porno where...
Okay, it is a weird porno.
Blastin' it!
"I'm sure a lot of people can relate PewDiePie to FilthyFrank."
I've drawn a lot of inspiration from FilthyFrank
and I do think we have a lot of similarities, but
I'm nowhere near as insane as that guy. *laughs*
"GradeAunderA destroyed you, bro." I love this.
Like I can literally tweet someone I know like half a joke and people would just be like,
OHHHH!
OHH SHIT! HE DID NOT SAY THAT!
That bitch got roasted!"
Like Grade didn't even say anything bad.
*thinking pause*
I think.
(Grade: All because of these three idiots!)
He better not.
*laughs* Fucking Hell. *laughs* Alright Bros.
Thank you so much for watching this video, leave a like if you enjoyed.
I got a new challenge for you.
Post something on Tumblr. Hashstag it #Pewdiepie.
I will review my Tumblr in the next video.
And if it's only Dan and Phil, I swear to fucking God!
Make me laugh. Make me cry. Make me wanna die.
'Cause I'm PewDiePie.
Bitch. Thank you Bros so much for watching,
thank you for leaving your comments.
I love reading comments, I really appreciate you,
for being interactive and not just watching my videos.
And as always, you ready for this?
Stay awesome, Bros.
You see this?
Brad, get in here, quick!
Yeah. Yeah, that's some good shit. This is fucked up.
Thi- I don't like this one. *gagging noise*
Japan, you're straight up weird man, what the fuck is this.